ragazzi ma se prima il video ci
chiudessimo un po d estate come si deve
vado a mettere il costume rega non non
fa domande sul pezzo iniziale ok non
porta bene a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti
a questo nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi
siamo tornati sui quiz ma in realtà devo
scattare un casino di pacchi come se non
l'aveste già notato mentre ragazzi
siccome vi era piaciuto tantissimo
l'episodio dedicato ai bachi siccome ne
ho ancora un miliardo andò anche dopo
questi no ancora un casino che ci
crediate o no ho deciso ragazzi fare un
secondo speciale nel blog dove lo dedico
praticamente soltanto allo scatto dei
pacchi e quindi regalini che possiamo
cominciare con lo scarto dei pacchi
anche dalle altre la settimana una
bellissima fanart creata da un'artista
contemporanea del 2004 ai ragazzi direi
che possiamo cominciare a suonare con il
primo che tra sfocia jacket mario
c'erano anche scattato già cechet mario
una patata cazzo ci devo trovare qua
dentro cos'è sembra un mega salame
mummificato non lo so pero che ti
piaccia tra toro e grazie mille ovvero
che ho trovato è un personaggio di di
caen con la maglietta fa vj fantastico
se un problema lui lui non è il pene
dopodiché i ragazzi ha trovato anche il
tempo che agli occhi esplosivi
fantastico ce ne sono un miliardo che
devo aprire chissà che cazzo scatolato
ragazzi non so cosa posso trovarci ma ho
seriamente power cos'è ma è un'altra
scatola quant'altro scatole su scatole
regalo è una cosa
call of duty black ops e call of duty
modern warfare grazie mille
ce l'avevo entrambi a questa canzone il
primo pacco arancione che perché
approdato da quando apro i pacchi cosa
mi mi rappresenta star approccio al naso
rosso che troppo figo un poster di
michael jackson credo la scritta fa vj
dietro ma vi ci fai sempre divertire
quinte videoteche sei un ragazzo
simpatico e carico c'è scritto capri co
però credo sia a carico o forse voleva
intendere capricorno continua così spero
che questi piccoli regali ti piacciono
ps grazie di esistere 6 straordinaria
soprattutto epico oggi spazio infinito è
la madonna è stata mila sono gli
occhiali di godzilla questi ragazzi
credetemi che vedo vedo tutto così vedo
qualsiasi capace una mano credo sia una
mano fantastico voglia fare una
scommessa quanti pacchi di escavo aprire
costi occhiali enormi credo che non ce
la farà la pena più dita perchè giuro
che non vedo un cazzo ma zero proprio
comincia seriamente aver paura di che
cazzo ci fosse qualche ho appena tentato
di uccidermi non so se avete visto ho
appena subito un attentato da una
scritta fa vj fantastico e verrà
ammazzato dio rega che cosa è questo
aquila cosa chiamate che non ce l'aveva
il bene lui sì però come cazzo fossili
giuro che sta roba mela incornicia
poiché parte grazie mille il capito la
barbie doveva infilarsi nello scatola
nicolò che c'hai pene giustamente
figurati che è tanto già anche ha
scritto ai log fa vj solo che è sporca
di sangue
il tuo sangue è mio
ragazzi ma che mi ha madato pacco dentro
ci sto trovando di tutto c'è roba troppo
strana vivo un tizio con un bene adesso
c'è adesso trovato pinocchio però senza
testa ragazzi capelli li adoro sembra
troppo tomic è un personaggio di un
video che anche giocando da piccolo
eccola la testa di pinocchio lega hanno
forse no trovate una mega matite ragazzi
questo mi fa mi fa paura c'è tipo
guardate che faccio e poi sembra un
puffo qua sembra un simpson e questo mi
fa cagare aldo se bastava beta è
fantastico aperti che non vedeva l'ora
di averli di morgan
ma questo ha scoraggiato questo ragazzi
c'è una una bici miniatura fantastica e
ho trovato un altro tizio che non so se
il ciclista che deve stare sulla bici e
poi d'altro non c'è il sellino quindi
che sta roba sarà in fila credo nel culo
ah sì sì sì già fessura proprio nel culo
per infilarlo perfetto credo che sto
prodotto i motivi ci faccia un male cane
però funziona bellissimo c'è anche fino
che figo quando queste luke celio c'è
gli occhi al padre praticamente una
figata sopra mente simulare happy meals
così è bellissimo figlio che è morto
cioè non perfetto ma sapete quante
ragazze mi dicono che sono un tipo
esplosivo era pessima questa proprio
una scimmia che a quanto felice un
cuoricino morbido con scritto friends on
the script dell'era glaciale che belli
che ha assistito favi tira la ghianda
brega questo scoreggia ragazzina una
fascia rosa con su scritto danza che non
è proprio c'è io non faccio proprio
danza però grazie a lei ha sì stavolta
invece dei giornali siete stati più
creativi cioè della carta igienica che
spero sia pulita in dubbio e non vado a
controllare ragazzi anche grazie all
share questo cos'è questo ma o di
un'altra fa ma perchè vi inviate far
uscire ma è un modo di dire che i miei
capelli fanno schifo che mi inviate
parlo chiesta cosa ancora non ho capito
ragazzi ma è una parrucca normale no
[Musica]
sto bene sto bene tranquilli quando
trovare delle palle gommose regalarci ci
lascia le penne anche lui mi sa che ci
lascia le penne in questa cosa
ragazzi ho trovato trovato il paradiso
ottenuto la carta igienica una carta
igienica verde cioè un chan dominato
sopra fa vi fa vigente la five igienica
grazie ad essa vi mancano pesa la porta
in bagno e fantastica perché ho trovato
ho trovato le tue dita di outlast sono
un dito di auto ci ho messo dei secoli
per ricercare queste qua cioè non sono
affatto a trovarle come l'ultima ragazza
decide di aprire più grande che questa è
più grandi in assoluto di tutti ma è
anche più leggero non so cosa c'è dentro
e no che figo non basta la testa di otto
da chiunque abbia fatto sto falco
appunto è fantastica e sembra una data
che io non riuscivo a fare ste cose da
piccolo sappia 3m kit di trucco grazie
mille anche stavolta perché c'è
veramente truccarmi la mia più grande
passione
[Musica]
già adesso devo leggermente un po a
mettere a posto però vabbè lasciamo
perdere e quindi ragazzi infine noi che
io ho te retroscudo pisa invece torna 6
lasciate un commento mi piace anche a
pagina di facebook e come ogni video
frate la descrizione senesi discreto che
ci vediamo il prossimo video ragazzi